there's been so much stress and anxiety
and negativity around the selection and
I think is having a real impact on me
and my emotional well-being so I just
want to take that energy that negativity
and turn into something positive and go
out there and do something useful with
my time this weekend we are going to go
canvass in Nevada for Hillary Rodham
Clinton this election has been crazy and
I feel a lot of fear one of the ways
that I can feel better about what
happens on Tuesday is knowing that this
weekend I made an effort to help get out
the vote this campaign was weird because
young people and people my age were less
politically active than usual and I feel
like I sort of subscribed to that as
well but as we get closer and closer to
the reality that Donald Trump might
become president I am definitely feeling
more of an urge to get involved when I
graduated college I became a community
organizer and now it's crunch time my
expectations for tomorrow are to be very
tired and very frustrated the swing
state so they've been getting a lot of
people calling them a lot of people
knocking on their door we're gonna drive
for hours we're gonna talk to a lot of
people who will probably yell at us and
then we're gonna drive for hours back to
LA let's go let's do it Nevada here we
come so I'm awake and the Sun is not
even up yet I really don't want to go I
just want to go back to bed
hrc fully rapping I'm secretly hoping
that nobody shows up they're the same
America gonna go do our duty
getting excited room
we're here in the office in Nevada
someone has made amazin I met Hillary
Clinton she's happy because she know
she's gonna win we just got our packets
and we're gonna head out to canvas I'm a
little nervous we're all be talking to
Democrats I'm just convincing people to
get out to vote already we're at a house
right now where we just got trained by
someone who walked us through what we're
supposed to say it's like very
overwhelming we just heard it once and
now we just go out and say it's people
we just got our walk packet so organizer
me is already thinking how to tear them
up make it the most efficient okay well
we're in the suburbs of Las Vegas and
we're about to start I feel like once I
got a couple houses down I'll get the
rhythm of it but right now yeah it's
scary you just knocked out our first
street I talked to you one person who
was like yeah I'm definitely a
Republican on to the next street I'm
feeling pretty bad because I just went
to like five or six houses and no one
was there someone sort of like made fun
of me sort of made me feel like man we
drove all the way here is this a good
use of our time just knock on the door
of someone who was having a baby shower
standing at the door and I was hearing
them like clap and cheer and
I just couldn't do it though I chickened
out and now I'm regretting it because
there were so many conversations to be
had about voting just talk to somebody
who was a Hillary supporter and said she
was gonna go vote on Tuesday she knew
where she was voting she was really
enthusiastic and supportive of us so
that felt really good just had an
amazing conversation with a very sweet
lady named Maria got through the whole
script with her she was like yes I am
voting I was like great do you know your
polling places how are you gonna get to
the polls you know what time you're
going he's got a voting plan probably
about ten houses deep and I'm actually
having fun every house is a new
adventure I am crying human tears I just
talked to a lady who definitely was like
not in the place where she wanted to
talk about anything and especially not
like with a stranger who's coming to
talk to her about an election she is
pissed off about by the end of the
conversation she was like so it's more
open we talked about like how important
Nevada is how much her voice counts here
and left that experience like just
feeling humbled and emotional glad that
I was able to have such a meaningful
conversation with someone today we've
been walking for like three hours now
and my legs are so [ __ ] tired my
whole body it's exhausted but it feels
good I want to keep going I just talked
to somebody who said she was going to
vote but she didn't know who yet she had
a little bit of a conversation I'm not
sure if she wanted to be swayed I'm not
sure if I did sway her but hopefully
she'll think about her decision this is
the polling place that we've been
talking about the convenient walk away
look how freaking beautiful it is about
is so tight right now Hillary Clinton's
at 49% and Trump is at like 50 so I feel
like we are making a difference than our
presence here matters that was worth
getting out of bed this morning even if
people aren't on your list you're kind
of interacting with them there's like
all these kids around right now and
they're like very interested like what
are you doing what are you doing like
and I was like yeah like I'm just a
neighbor coming on make sure like all
your parents are ready to vote like can
you talk to them for me make sure they
are and this one girl was like yeah
Hillary Clinton it's funny because out
here you realize that you're like a face
of the campaign and you really do want
to be nice to everybody and even people
who disagree with you there's a bunch of
people just sitting around in a driveway
I hear them as I was walking away being
like did you vote yet and like just
knowing that like my presence is
stimulating those conversations is super
cool this process is just making it so
clear to me how personal this is
and how every vote does matter I just
knocked on the door and it was this
latina woman and she said you know she's
been watching the election on the news
and she can't take it anymore and she
doesn't want to vote and it was really
upsetting that someone who normally
would vote Democratic just like didn't
want to vote at all try talking to her
and she became sort of interested she
was able times the poll close maybe
she'll go out but it was heartbreaking
because as we were saying you know the
swing state your vote really matters her
daughter was shouting Hillary Clinton
Hillary Clinton and I wanted to be like
listen to your daughter she wants to see
Hillary Clinton in the White House you
want to see woman in the White House I
really hope that woman votes
I thought everyone be mean to me a
couple people were mean to me but so
many people just want to talk to you and
want to like discuss issues with you've
been really heartening it's getting a
pretty dark out at the beginning of the
night I was so nervous and at this point
I just want to keep going I feel like
fearless ringing on doors I could talk
to a million people tonight I had this
amazing conversation with this woman who
was like very excited to build very
excited about Hillary and then I met her
husband who was similarly excited about
Hillary but he was a felon and he
couldn't vote he was very informed he
knew who he wanted to vote for and it
was really hard to see that he couldn't
exercise this right that he has just had
an awesome conversation with a lady who
recently moved to this house she's not
registered here she's registered in her
last location so we made sure that she
was like heading to her old polling
location is making sure those logistics
were in place overall it's been a really
worthwhile experience and it makes me
want to get involved more I want to like
do phone banking make sure everyone gets
up to vote we're wrapping up just a
couple more houses he tired ready to go
home but let's finish this up I was so
tired when I got back I just collapsed
into my bed and I felt so happy to have
gone it was like a 180 from how I felt
that morning there were some
conversations where I really did feel
that their opinions had changed a little
bit they were more likely to get out
there and vote and that's so cool and
powerful I'm so glad we went it has been
an election where a lot of us have felt
like helpless and I forgot that being
active makes you feel so much more like
involved and able to do something I
definitely feel a different sort of
investment when I look at these numbers
I feel that I can do something to change
them we have to do better we can do
better and I feel
the sense of like wanting to participate
there isn't anything that replaces that
feeling is like making a difference in
your community showing up at someone's
door and being able to listen to what's
affecting their lives is really
important to the political process and
like really important to like my life as
a person who lives in this country and
wants to improve the country there was
nothing I would have rather done the
weekend before the election and knock
doors in a swing state